I am very awkward socially unless I'm
across town
I don't I become this other person when
I am in a costume I am not shy at all
when I am NOT myself
so what got me interested in cosplaying
is a there's a story to that I loved
Japanese animation since I was like
about 4 or 5 years old it all started
with Sailor Moon and then DBZ is thin
Cardcaptor Sakura ninja robot speed
racer I found it so unbelievably cool
that someone could look exactly like an
anime character the makeup the eyes
but family reactions my mom has been
more accepting than my father
but that's recently for eight years I've
just coped with everything that they
said to me thus far was your extended
family not very much on good terms they
do not accept it at all about four years
ago comic-con started in India which was
our first proper convention and after
that we saw this boom of import of wigs
and more material like fake nails and
crazy contact lenses on online stores my
nan cosplaying friends think it's really
cool that I do is something like that
nothing stops me from my from achieving
my dream a bride without Hina in India
would be probably like not even accepted
it has been an old saying